[Music]
this week on cue a author and law
professor Brad Snyder professor
Schneider discusses his book the house
of truth a Washington political salon
and the foundations of American
liberalism
[Music]
Brad Snyder your book is called the
house of truth where did you get the
title the title is what the people who
lived in this house on Dupont Circle
called their political salon and and
they weren't calling calling it that in
sort of a self aggrandizing way but
really in a self mocking way it
characterized their debates with the
hero of the house of justice Oliver
Wendell Holmes jr. who thought there was
no such thing as truth but the people in
the house thought there was such a thing
as truth if you could just
corral enough experts and get the right
facts you could arrive at truth so this
was part of their philosophical debates
with Holmes he said a couple of things a
salon and Dupont Circle and all that
explain what that's all what is this a
law so that it was a political gathering
place this was a Washington with not a
lot of automobiles with no television a
little bit of radio and people
entertained themselves by having dinner
parties and in 1912 some disgruntled
members of the Taft administration began
inviting very prominent people and not
so prominent people over for dinner to
discuss the political ideas of the day
and their main political idea was the
day was they thought the Taft was a
horrible president at the way to save
the country was to bring Theodore
Roosevelt back to the White House wife
you know who knows about what they like
about him well I think part of it was a
cult of personality but also Roosevelt
saw the wisdom of their ideas about
labor and about the rights of workers
about minimum wage laws maximum our laws
the rights of labor unions and that was
their principal issue in around 1911
1912 given the industrial accidents and
the unsafe working conditions and the
really low wages that were plaguing men
women and children at the time so where
were you when this became an idea for a
book I was living in a house not far
from the actual house of truth I was
living at 1920s Street on the northwest
side of Dupont Circle and about two
blocks away
well this
ten years ago or so ten years ago how
did you find out about the house I found
out about the house by reading history
and Ted white who's a wonderful
historian and biographer of Oliver
Wendell Holmes wrote in his
bibliographical notes he wrote that not
a lot of things have been written about
Justice Holmes and his young friends
from the house of truth and then I sort
of a light bulb went off in my head that
I could use the house as a vehicle to
discuss the evolution of American law
and politics and liberal law and
politics
I mean before the New Deal before we
talk about the individual I want to put
on the screen the ages of these several
of these men all men that were in the
house at the time and one of the most
interesting number on there is it Oliver
Wendell Holmes was seventy years old and
then you have a Robert Valentine who was
37 Gutzon Borglum and 44 he's the guy
that did the Mount Rushmore and other
things Louis Brandeis 44 and Felix
Frankfurter was 29 and walter lippmann
was 20 to start with Oliver Wendell
Holmes a Holmes at age 70 had been on
the court almost ten years and he was
marking down the days to his retirement
from the Supreme Court he felt like that
his time on the Supreme Court um was
unsatisfying he really couldn't escape
the shadow of his famous father
I'm dr. Oliver Wendell Holmes senior who
is a very famous physician poet who
founded the Atlantic Monthly and you
know he was ready to go he was
frustrated with his colleagues and then
he meets this young crowd of liberal
intellectuals whose ideas he didn't
really believe in but he recognized the
brilliance of the young men associated
with this house and they recognized
Holmes's brilliance as you know
philosophy is wit his intellectual
curiosity and they really bonded with
each other and so the young people
associated with this house took Holmes
from a relatively obscure justice in
1912 into a liberal icon by the time
Holmes leaves the court you know in the
early 30s you say in your book that
Robert Valentine was one of the most
important people to get you the material
that you need
who was he so Robert Valentine as
someone who's really been lost to
history he was TAFEs Commissioner of
Indian Affairs and in 1911 he was living
in the house of truth which is 1787 19th
Street with his wife an infant daughter
and his infant daughter had an
undiagnosed milk allergy while his wife
and daughter went home to New England so
that nurse the daughter back to health
and Valentine found himself a bachelor
in this house and so he started inviting
a few of his friends one of whom was
Felix Frankfurter the Future for Supreme
Court justice the other was when for
Denison a friend of his from Harvard
College he was working in the TAF
Justice Department and this is really
how the salon took shape the reason why
Valentine was really important to the
house is twofold he was really the
house's visionary when it came to Labor
Relations matters he sort of set the
agenda of the house and secondly as you
alluded to his correspondence was
incredibly important because Valentine's
writing on a daily basis
to his wife who's back in New England
about the comings and goings and who was
at dinner at various nights at the house
and a remarkable woman named Dorothy
Colville who I think in my
acknowledgments was friends with not
only Valentine's daughter but his
granddaughter and Valentine's papers
were languishing in a barn in Vermont
until this woman I'm Dorothy Koval
rescued them you know
preserve them and donated them to the
Massachusetts Historical Society where
they were unprocessed and unknown to
historians until I started my book and
we got a grant to process Valentine's
papers and it was really almost like a
diary of the house so how did you find
out about the Valentine papers how does
anyone find out about anything these
days I just sort of googled Robert
Valentine papers and this woman Dorothy
Koval's a LinkedIn page shows up and one
of the things that was on her LinkedIn
page was an archivist Robert Valentine
papers and then I just put on my
journalist hat and started you know
tracking her down and she was a
wonderful and incredibly helpful
the entire process because she she not
only had preserved the papers but she
knew two generations of the family and
she you know helped me fill in facts
which weren't always easy to fill in you
talked about the Massachusetts
Historical Society we've gotten a lot
from them over the years so you say
unprocessed when you first showed up
there were they in just in boxes they
were just in boxes they hadn't even sort
of arranged them in folders and they
were kind enough at that early stage to
allow me to look at the collection when
it was unprocessed which not a lot of
our institutions will allow you to do
but they trusted me to be able to do
that and it was incredibly helpful
because it allowed me to get the book
rolling once I realized I had
Valentine's papers I realized I had a
book and I had material that no one else
had the purposes of discussion how long
was this house of truth important well
that's a great I mean and writing the
book oh it was about a six year period
that took me to to write the book I
thought in sort of an act of hubris that
the book would take me two to three
years to write like some of my prior
books but this was you know a four
character narrative that spanned 20-some
years and you know six years and two
kids later I was finished let's talk
about we talked about one of the people
on this book he had four pictures on the
cover of the book and one of them is
Felix Frankfurter who was he Felix
Frankfurter was like many people who
come to Washington a young idealistic
lawyer who had gone to work for Henry
Stimson who was Taft Secretary of War as
a sort of like Stimson's counsel almost
and and frankfurter had worked for
Stimpson in the US Attorney's Office in
the Southern District of New York where
um Simpson had been the US Attorney
but frankfurter really it's if
Valentine's the visionary of the house
that then then frankfurter is the one
who just has this talent for bringing
all these different people into the
house he's a huge extrovert he's
incredibly interested in ideas and he
really carries on the house Valentine
passes away quite suddenly dies of a
heart attack
I'm at Delmonico's restaurant in
nineteen
sixteen with frankfurter and others
sitting around the table and it's
frankfurter who really carries on the
house from Valentine and helps found the
New Republic
I'm with the fourth person on that book
which is who's a very young and
precocious walter Lippmann as we showed
in 1911 I believe he was 22 years old
here is a picture of otter Lippmann who
was he
walter Lippmann at the time that he
joined with this frankfurter New
Republic crowd was you know a very
precocious Harvard college graduate and
he was a socialist and it and it was
when he became when he joined the New
Republic with Herbert Crowley felix
frankfurter and others that he became
more of a traditional liberal you know
over time and during the course of my
book I discussed you know how Lippmann
makes the move from socialist to liberal
to conservative columnist for the New
York Herald Tribune how conservative was
he at the end I think it was pretty
conservative he was isolationist but
before World War two he wrote some
appeasing columns I'm about the Nazis
that I'm caused he and frankfurter not
to speak for a long long period of time
so he opposed FDR in 1932 for the
presidency and then subsequently opposed
FDR for re-election in 36 and 40 so I
would say quite conservative even though
you know late in life he did oppose even
more why Gutzon Borglum on the cover
yeah good luck this is the question that
everyone asked me about the book what
does the man who built Mount Rushmore
have anything to do with early 20th
century liberals like Felix Frankfurter
well I'm Borglum like frankfurter like
Lippmann work was convinced that
Theodore Roosevelt should return to the
White House in 1912 and was very active
in Roosevelt's bull moose presidential
campaign and that's what brought Borglum
into the house but it wasn't just this
one moment in time and Borglum stayed
friends with Oliver Wendell Holmes the
book opens with Borglum drawing on the
dining room table cloth at the house of
truth his precursor to Mount Rushmore
which was a Confederate Memorial in
Stone Mountain Georgia and Holmes who
had been wound
three times during the civil war and
really admired as Confederate
counterparts was just astonished about
the idea of carving historical figures
into the side of a mountain and Borglum
his friendship with Holmes and
frankfurter lasts until the very end of
their lives and the day after Holmes
dies in 1935 borglum's in Holmes's
residence you know at 1730 I Street
making a death mask of Oliver Wendell
Holmes his face so you know this was a
friendship that goes all the way from TR
in 1912 to FDR I'm in 1932 and if you
know if not for FDR there is no Mount
Rushmore he was able to bring huge
amounts of federal funding that allowed
Mount Rushmore to be completed where are
you from originally I'm from right
outside of Washington DC in Potomac
Maryland where'd you go to college I
went to Duke University don't hate me
for that one no and where did you go for
your law degree I went to Yale and where
have you been teaching I was I've been
teaching for the last nine years at the
University of Wisconsin and then next
year I'll be starting at Georgetown Law
School and what do you consider your
expertise in the law when you teach
what's the what do you focus on well the
older I get the less expertise I think I
have but constitutional law and Supreme
Court history those are my two main
areas of expertise with a little bit of
a side light on sports law you've done a
couple books on sports a couple of books
on bass and they were named what the
first one was called beyond the shadow
of the senators about the Homestead
Grays a Negro league baseball team when
they played in Washington during the
1940s and the second book which is more
legal it's called a well paid slave
about Curt Flood and his fight for free
agency in the early 1970s let's go back
to this house at 17 27 19th Street
Northwest here in Washington DC you have
a picture in the book of Felix
Frankfurter standing on the steps and it
was a brownstone type now it's painted
all white have you ever been inside that
house I have and I'm dying to get into
the house
but you know so busy kind of finishing
the book and I had pictures from the
inside of the house at the time you know
in the teens that I felt like since the
house had been remodeled a couple times
that it wasn't gonna help me with
finishing the book but I would love to
get inside the house and see it I'd love
to get into the upper floor crow's nest
where Walter Lippman lived with his new
wife of a so you know B it'd be
fascinating for me to step foot in the
house and during this time period is six
years how many people lived in this
house nervous it's it's it's it was
longer than six years it was over in
1912 in 1919 the problem was once the
run-up to World War one starts people
start coming and going in the house you
know five to six people lived in that
house at any one time you know it's sort
of the height of the house you had Felix
Frankfurter you had Robert Valentine
Winfred Dennison you had a Canadian
citizen working in the Justice
Department Lauren Christie living there
you had a member an attache at the
British Embassy living there as well so
that was five people initially so you
know people just sort of were coming and
going
I want to juxtapose two things I want to
go back to that chart that we showed of
how old people were in 1911 I believe
we'll go back and check that and then I
want to show a picture from 1925 but
first let's do the the 1911 which lists
all of the people that were in that
house there you have the age of people
in 1911 that we've just been talking
about the youngest being walter Lippmann
the oldest being Oliver Wendell Holmes
then I want to switch to the 1925 photo
of the Supreme Court and have you break
this down because sitting there on the
court among other people is Oliver
Wendell Holmes jr. who is as you can see
right there second from the left but on
the far left is James McReynolds and up
top on the I mean on the far right is
Louis Brandeis in the middle is the
former president itíd States William
Howard Taft it sounded like a dumb
question but what's he doing there
well the Taft has the
a unique distinction of being you know a
former president sitting on the Supreme
Court us as Chief Justice you know a
move that people speculated that you
know might be in Obama's future I doubt
it but people speculated that that Taft
really helped remake that court into a
much more conservative Court when um
Warren Warren Harding becomes president
and liberals like Felix Frankfurter are
kind of in the wilderness Harding in
just a very short period of time he he's
only spent three years in office but he
appoints four members of the court
including Taft and after TAFEs appointed
he really helps Harding select very
conservative people for the Supreme
Court and tilts that court in a
conservative direction that the three
liberals in that photo are Brandeis
Harlan Fiske stone who was in the upper
right corner of that photo and then some
people would say that Holmes is liberal
although he's a little difficult to
categorize certainly not liberal by
today's standards I gotta I gotta bring
up the fact that James McReynolds on the
far left from Kentucky Louis Brandeis on
the far right from Kentucky tell us that
relationships fascinating both of them
nominees of Woodrow Wilson right and and
McReynolds of course was Wilson's
attorney general who had a liberal
reputation as a trust buster both before
he joined the Wilson administration and
while he was in the administration of
course he goes on to become one of the
most conservative and supremely racist
and anti-semitic Supreme Court justices
in history but just to tell you how
diverse the the people were who were
dining at the house of truth when
McReynolds becomes the Attorney General
he dines at the house of truth Robert
Valentine comes down from Massachusetts
and Felix Frankfurter arranges his
dinner with McReynolds and frankfurter
and McReynolds get into this debate
about civil service and about whether or
not people should be hired to work in
the Justice Department based on merit or
on patronage and of course frankfurter
thinks people should be hired based on
merit and and and McReynolds says but
what about all these people who've been
you know approaching me
about getting his senators and other
folks about getting their favorite
political candidates hired and he's in
frankfurters retort was you know
Attorney General you know you're
responsible to the American people
you're not not to the politicians who
are knocking on your door for
constituents to get it get into the
Justice Department there have been
stories that McReynolds wouldn't even
sit in the same room was the Brandeis
tab a picture taken what was that
relationship personal relations so the
the McReynolds photos story is
apocryphal there's a wonderful article
in the journal of Supreme Court history
that says you know there's no truth to
the rumor about there was the rumor was
there was no photo at 1923
because McReynolds refused to have his
photo taken next to Brandeis that's not
true but what is true is that McReynolds
was incredibly nasty to Brandeis and
incredibly nasty with Cardozo who was
the second Jewish justice and you know
so that sort of enmity that most people
think was based on their religion it's
true we go back to that photo Harlan
Fiske stone had just gotten on the court
in 1925 what was unique about his
confirmation process well he was the
first Supreme Court justice to testify
before the United States Senate now he
testified about it just very discreet
issue when he had been an attorney
general he had been movor his attorney
not Hoover's attorney general Coolidge
as Attorney General but he was the first
person ever to testify the first person
to testify and about any subject was
Felix Frankfurter sort of an open-ended
testimony was 1939 and after frankfurter
testified in 1939 every Supreme Court
nominee testified after frankfurter so
frankfurter started the tradition but
the first person to testify was Stone
the person we really haven't talked
about and who sort of the shadow figure
in the house is Louis Brandeis because
his nomination by Wilson you know
liberals were sort of outraged by the
nomination of McReynolds and McReynolds
had become this huge conservative force
on the court and they wanted a liberal
and when when Nils Wilson nominated
Brandeis they were apparently
on the Senate floor they couldn't
believe that Wilson had nominated
somebody who had such a radical
reputation and one of the people most
outraged about Brandeis his nomination
was then ex-president William Howard
Taft whose comments privately about the
Brandeis nomination were pretty ugly and
really romantic I'm really drifted into
some anti-semitic stereotypes I'm not I
wasn't willing to say in the book the
Taft himself was anti-semitic he was
making the comments to another Jewish
person but the comments if you just read
them in the abstract talking about
Brandeis as Zionists activities as his
theoretical sorry circumcision that so
that he could um get Jewish Americans
behind him for the court it was kind of
ugly as you know it was such a different
age and Brandeis has a university named
after him up in the Boston suburbs but
Harvard and you talk about this the
Lowell the president of our was
anti-semitic and they had a Jewish quota
what was that about
yeah well so Lowell was in fact Lowell
during the Brandeis confirmation process
which um before Merrick garland Brandeis
was still uh waited longest for a Senate
Judiciary Committee hearing no no
nominee had waited longer than Brandeis
and as I had to add in my book until
Merrick garland but there was a huge
petition by all of the finest citizens
of Boston led by a Lawrence Lowell um
yep the president of Harvard
anti-semitic president of Harvard asking
the United States Senate not to confirm
Brandeis that they felt like that he was
dishonest and a trickster and you know
all these sort of stereotypes and what
the New Republic did which was really
brilliant was showed all of the personal
connections of all these people all of
this petition of Boston Brahmins and in
the the New Republic it was really
Lippmann and Felix Frankfurter who were
leading the charge for Brandeis as
confirmation showed that this was just
in group Prejudice right about my Jewish
you know Walter Lippman was Jewish Felix
Frankfurter was Jewish also Lippmann was
a bit of a self-hating Jew but you know
they showed that all these Boston
Brahmins
sign this petition against Brandeis it
was just in group loyalty and and
nothing else they tried to stay away
from charges of anti-semitism they did
not want to make it into a Jewish thing
well you get the sense that back in
those days some of the Jewish people
were anti black yes or didn't care about
civil rights yeah I think I would plan
about I think everybody associated with
this house frankfurter Lippmann Brandeis
race wasn't a salient issue for them you
know they were they cared about the
rights of workers and it took Oliver
Wendell Holmes jr. in some of his
opinions including a 1923 case known as
Moore v Dempsey which found for the
first time that the mob dominated
criminal trials of southern blacks
violated the due process clause that's
the first time the Supreme Court struck
down a state criminal conviction under
the due process clause that was a huge
moment in putting fair criminal trials
on the liberal agenda and linking the
idea of fair criminal trials with race
Felix Frankfurter became a justice in 39
did he take Louis Brandeis to seat no he
took Cardozo seat and 39 in fact there
was a clamor for Brandeis to retire to
make way for frankfurter and I'm writing
about this in my next book my next books
about Justice frankfurter and what I'm
currently writing is a chapter about how
and why Felix Frankfurter gets nominated
at the Supreme Court most people assumed
it was just a done deal because of his
close relationship with Franklin
Roosevelt and that's just not the case
when you hear judge Korsak corsets it's
hard to say sitting and is in his
nomination hearing say that the court is
not political he's not political and
then you think back to Felix Frankfurter
and Louis Brandeis and for that matter
Oliver Wendell Holmes what's your
reaction well I mean I think of those
three that you just mentioned
frankfurter Brandeis and Holmes that
Holmes was the least political right he
wasn't a political animal at all he
didn't read newspapers his only source
of news was the New Republic and the
reason why he met read the New Republic
was because he admired Herbert Crowley
he had
walter lippmann and he admired Felix
Frankfurter so he read the magazine but
other than that he didn't read news
didn't care about news didn't really
care much about politics but frankfurter
and Brandeis were real political animals
I think I would separate politics from
constitutional values I think all
justices had come to the position with
certain constitutional values but in the
case of free leagues frankfurter how
close was he to FDR when he be you know
and he was still on the court when he
became very and both Brandeis and
frankfurter engaged in extrajudicial
activity what I mean by that is you know
they were still active in political
affairs in the executive branch while
sitting on the court which today we
would consider you know a gross
violation of the separation of powers
but back then you know people did that
you've mentioned in every public several
times it's all over your book who
started it in what year herbert crowley
started it in 1914 really in conjunction
with people who lived in the house Felix
Frankfurter was one of the original
incorporators the New Republic judge
learn at hand was involved in the
founding of the New Republic and then he
found this young socialist walter
Lippmann to be an editor of the New
Republic and originally they saw it as
an outlet it's the original 1914 cover
there it is yeah originally they saw it
as an outlet for what they regarded as
the Theodore Roosevelt's ideas this idea
of a big federal government right they
said them Hamiltonian means for
Jeffersonian ends they believed that
they could help people through the
federal government what will go back to
that parse that Hamiltonian right which
is this ideals for Jeffersonian end yeah
right you prefer direct people's Liberty
you could protect people's freedom
through a robust federal government
right so III that was their idea and
Theodore Roosevelt really embodied that
idea but what happened is after Theodore
Roosevelt lost the White House in 1912
he became a huge critic of Woodrow
Wilson particularly Wilson's foreign
policy he was elected in 12 right
literals I was elected in a 3-way race
really a four-way race a Wilson was
elected but you know Taft and Roosevelt
split or
looking votes and Wilson the Democrat
was the first Democrat since Grover
Cleveland to be in the White House so
all those folks that were in that the
house of truth and when I asked you
about that in a second
how many of them were for Woodrow Wilson
so Brandeis was for Wilson and the
people associated with the house were
really upset that Brandeis was for
Wilson and they didn't like it that
Brandeis was writing articles in
Harper's Weekly that were these Pro
Wilson ideas and they wanted an outlet
for their protea our ideas and that's
how you get the New Republic what
happens is they start being critical of
TR and they see TR as hypocritical on
issues such as the German invasion of
Belgium where at the time TR said one
thing and then later on TR was
criticizing the Wilson administration
for not I'm taking more forceful action
after I'm Germany invades Belgium before
World War one and TR gets really angry
at the criticism he's really
thin-skinned and he calls the editors of
the New Republic three anemic Gentiles
and three international juice and at
that point their relations are done and
before the founding of the magazine they
were quite close minded people back
didn't want to separate Jews from
everybody else you know I think there
was just a lot of xenophobia there was a
lot of immigration more and more Jews
were occupying high places in the
government people like Louis Brandeis
people like Felix Frankfurter but there
was a lot of anti-immigrant sentiment
too at this time and I think it was part
of it well on that note I ought to ask
you about Sacco and Vanzetti you've
spoken a lot about that did you do a
book on that I didn't I didn't but it
it's like a book within the book here in
the house of truth because it involves
every single person associated with the
house who was Sacco and who was Vanzetti
and this picture has Vanzetti on the
left and Sacco on the right okay so um
on the left is Bartolomeo Vanzetti and
on the right is Nicola sack
the Sacko is the one without the
mustache and there are two Italian
anarchists who are convicted outside of
Boston of robbery and murder of a
paymaster right they they they steal a
company's payroll and kill the guard who
is guarding the payroll the trial was in
1921 the appeals process goes on for six
years it it causes all sorts of national
and international attention the
Communist Party was deeply involved in
the case but it wasn't until Felix
Frankfurter and early 1927 decided to
read the record for what he record he he
had read some of the motions and you
thought the prosecution had not been on
the up-and-up so he decided to read the
record and he writes a very long article
in the Atlantic Monthly about the case
and turns that long article in tort to
his short book and that really turns the
case in 1927 into a national cause celeb
and the cause is that Sacco and Vanzetti
had been railroaded they had not been
afforded a failed fair trial and that
what was on trial was their Italian
anarchist beliefs and not whether or not
they committed the crimes we've had you
go back and look at the video and
there's a lot of video to see they're
huge crowds and they march into the into
the court there they're handcuffed and
all that why were the crowds so big in
those days what was the issue for people
that lived in the Boston area it's just
a sensational case right it was well one
of the so-called trials of the century
it's a that's amazing footage I'm
guessing that that footage is on the way
to they're being sentenced right they
weren't actually sentenced to death
until 1927 so it was after the
publication of frankfurters book that
they were sentenced to death and what
had come out after the publication of
frankfurters book was to trial judge
Webster Thayer had made all these
extrajudicial comments during the trial
to people and he would say just wait
until you see what I do to those
anarchistic bastards because where were
they from Sacco and Vanzetti
I mean a member from it they were from
Italy right in fact I think Sacco what
was trying to repatriate back to Italy
before he was arrested why had they come
to the United States I don't know the
answer to that you know what did it mean
to be an anarchist oh this is really
good and hard question I think in some
ways that means I'm the enter the the
overthrow of the government you know
they were they were anti the US
government they were anti the US
government's involvement in world war
one where they an Turkish slice
communists I think so I think that's a
good way to to characterize them right
they were they were certainly not
capitalist and from what you know and I
know you know a lot about this case were
they guilty i hard to say right so the
historical consensus is that Sacco was
guilty and Vanzetti wasn't it was really
kind of beside the point though you know
potentially exculpatory witnesses were
withheld from the defense a lot of
witnesses who were Pro prosecution were
badgered into testifying the ballistics
expert for the state gave testimony that
the prosecutors used to sort of mislead
the jury about the bullets um in Sacco's
vent on possession so you know there was
a lot of evidence that existed even just
based on the transcript itself that the
trial wasn't on the up-and-up and then
the profit the judges comments you know
about the defendants while the trial was
going on any one of those things today
would have resulted in a new trial and I
think that's what liberals really wanted
and frankfurter again really enlists
everyone in this liberal network that he
creates at the house of truth to try to
save Sacco and Vanzetti what were these
people what were they like what was
Felix Frankfurter like complete
extrovert
all right you wouldn't even able to get
a word in during this interview if you
were interviewing how tall was that you
very short he's five-six spoke with the
slight German accent he was from where
Austria Vienna Austria prominent Vienna
Austria family can be came to this
country at age eleven speaking not a
word of English and by his early
twenties his number one
class at Harvard Law School and by 30
he's worked for three US President
presidential administrations he was you
know in the he was a prosecutor under
Theodore Roosevelt he befriends Theodore
Roosevelt then he works in the Taft
administration and then he works in the
Wilson administration all before he's
thirty it's a remarkable rise would you
have liked him personally anything oh
yeah oh yeah I think everybody um who
knew Felix Frankfurter on a social basis
liked him he just had this magnetism
this charisma I mean William Rehnquist
when he clerked for Robert Jackson he
wrote Rehnquist writes in his memoirs he
was just attracted to Frankfort there
was something about him the way he would
grab people on the arm with a firm grip
he was intense you know one of the they
did an exhibit at Harvard Law School
about frankfurter and it was called a
passionate intensity that really sums up
frankfurter what was the Louis Brandeis
like Brandeis was a little more of a
cult fish right and part of the reason
why the house I'm gravitated more to
homes and to Brandeis Brandeis had this
real reserve I mean it was almost a
studied reserve he just didn't a moat
and even his letters if you read
Brandeis as letters they're bullet
points it says one period to period and
they're just one line after another
there's no feeling in those letters very
businesslike what was Oliver Wendell
Holmes like I think he was a lot like
frankfurter he was an extrovert he liked
people he liked to talk about philosophy
you like to talk about ideas I think
it's much of you know they were
attracted to Holmes for a number of
reasons some of them the political some
of them legal but also just his cult of
personality Holmes just had this twinkle
in his blue eyes and really connected
with this younger generation I want to
ask you about
Gutzon Borglum but I want to put up on
the screen the Stone Mountain carving
and there's a story here as you all know
what was it and what happened to this
Borglum in their early teens begins to
carve these Confederate leaders
including Jefferson Davis and Stonewall
Jackson into the side
Stone Mountain Georgia and he also joins
the Ku Klux Klan and enlists the Ku Klux
Klan in financing the project that at a
certain point
Borglum had a falling-out with the Klan
and he gets fired as the sculptor of the
Stone Mountain project and he has to
flee for he destroys his models and he
runs for his life through the hills of
Georgia into North Carolina so did he
how far did he ever get on the side of
the mountain the only he had finished
sort of two figures and was starting on
a third what's the relationship between
boredom and the this crowd plus where
any of these people in this crowd
involved in Rushmore well not at
Rushmore yeah well to some degree
Borland was a became a political animal
after Theodore Roosevelt's 1912
presidential race some would say that
his politics were more instrumental that
he was just interested in people funding
his you know big projects but but I
don't think that's only the case Borglum
was from the West
he was really interested in the plight
of Western farmers and in the plight of
workers and his politics and in many
ways were aligned with people like Felix
Frankfurter was a sort of a populism
attached to borglum's politics and then
of course there were people in the
Roosevelt administration who helped
Borglum a mate make Mount Rushmore it
was really this project at the height of
the Great Depression right it was
initially funded by Coolidge then Hoover
gave it a bit of a boost and Coolidge
was resulted right as he was leaving
office gave Borglum his initial federal
funding which never would have happened
after the Great Depression hit and then
Hoover carried it on a little bit but
then Borglum campaigns hard for FDR
and an FDR really enables Rushmore to
become rough here's a tiny little bit we
can see what he looked like and sounded
like in this video we're going to show
that's important when do you think this
work could be completed mr. Bartlett
I'm trying to finish it so that they
figure to be done by 1935 sufficiently
to allow the president to unveil a and
inscription well that may take they may
take another year we're planning to
start them this year and that may need
to work on until 1936 if you're a bit
out there
I have a half you know the national park
service runs Mount Rushmore and what few
people know they also have quite a nice
archive of mount Rushmore's history and
that was incredibly helpful to the
project that was a great clip that you
just showed um FDR does unveil borglum's
Jefferson in 1936 which is a huge moment
caught on the newsreels um I think
there's a photo of it um in my book but
but Borglum of course never actually
finished Mount Rushmore the inscription
never gets done then Borglum dies I'm in
1941 and his son put some finishing
touches on the project but the Mount
Rushmore was I've never really finished
in the elaborate way the Borglum wanted
to and what I say in my book that Mount
Rushmore is kind of this imperfect
symbol of American liberalism its belief
in big government in the regulatory
state and in you know funding great
projects like this but you know also has
its flaws you know some of the blind
spots of liberals as you pointed out was
race during this period and Mount
Rushmore
carved on sacred Indian land so um
although Mount Rushmore is really
celebrating our government there's also
a negative side to it as well go back to
the New Republic you mentioned that it
can is there any way you can put that
into context of today how big a deal was
a small publication how big was it then
by the way in pages yeah it was it was
pretty big and pretty thick and you know
it was really the insiders publication
Littman had amazing sources especially
in the Wilson administration in the
run-up to World War one and when the
u.s. finally enters the war was when the
New Republic was really at its height in
terms of circulation the exact figures I
can't give you off the top of my head
but I would figure 15 to 20,000 but it
was really an insider's um publication
near the Republican presidential
candidate Charles Evans Hughes and and
you know past and future Supreme Court
justice and he subscribed the
publication you know the the list of
people who subscribed the New Republic
was really a who's who of Washington if
you wanted to find out what was going on
in Washington you read the New Republic
thing like it today no cuz you're the
the news media is so much more
democratized today with the internet and
and Washington was such a much smaller
place than it was really amazing about
the house of truth how the people
associated with it whether it was
frankfurter or Lippmann or anyone else
who lived in the house had access to
corridors of power in such an easy way
did any of these did these folks that
we've been talking about did they marry
and did they have children
yeah and are any of any of the ancestors
still around yeah it's interesting so
walter Lippmann never have children he
his wife was the first woman to live in
the house of truth after it became about
Japan is what first wife Faye um Felix
Frankfurter married he'd met his wife
Marion at the house of truth they never
had any children Oliver Wendell Holmes
and his wife never had any children
Brandeis had two children he had two
daughters Elizabeth and Susan and they
did have children and and some of bran
dices grandchildren are still living and
one of them used to teach at the
University of Wisconsin law school did
you know him or her I've met him I've
met him he was a little after my time
but I've met him at some events so yeah
there's some offspring from the house of
truth and of course
Borglum married and had two children and
I know some of his offspring as well his
I think is it either his
great-granddaughter or his granddaughter
was was incredibly helpful to me in
writing this book he named his son
Lincoln didn't have anything to do what
he was doing at Mount right I think he
named his son Lincoln because he greatly
admired Lincoln and did an amazing
carving straight out of marble of April
Lincoln that's--it's I'm in the US
Capitol Rotunda today and that Lincoln's
son Robert said was the best likeness of
his father have to ask you about water
Lippmann's second marriage and how that
happens yeah um
Walter Lippman was having an affair with
the wife of his best friend Helen and I
think I mean that it is what it is right
you know he he uh his first wife and you
were really mismatched his his first
wife Faye liked the theater and it
really wasn't interested in politics and
and and his first wife was really more
of a New York person and Lippmann you
know
just lived and breathed politics and his
his best friend was Hamilton fish
Armstrong a pretty prominent foreign
policy person and and he was having a
long-term affair with his wife and I
think it wasn't until their love letters
were discovered that they went public
with the affair and it really cost
Lippmann some of his dear friends people
like I'm learnin hand really sort of
4-time severed his friendship with
Lippmann only always learned hand learn
at hand
who has not to met just a great name but
was one of the great federal judges
never to be on the Supreme Court of the
United States what made him so great he
was a really good writer he just had a
way with language quite in the same way
that Holmes did Holmes was a beautiful
writer and in hand I'm also and you know
hand was you know one of the integral
members of this crowd right hand would
come to the house of truth hand was
friends with Holmes and with frankfurter
and Lippmann and and and croley and so
he was thick as thieves with these
people hand was all in favor of Theodore
Roosevelt in 1912 as well currently
being the founder with wit mouse with
Lippmann and with frankfurter of the of
the New Republic there were some others
did it cost a lot of money then and
where did they go to have huge financial
backing from door they had a couple of
financial backers one of whom was
associated with JP Morgan
they had Dorothy Payne Whitney whose
family you know had a Hugh
fortune so they had you know a
husband-wife team with just a lot of
money we're not unlike today when a lot
of these magazines have billionaire
backers not only like Jeff Bezos backing
the The Washington Post
oh yeah weekly standard which is Philip
Anschutz and you can go to and also all
the the websites yeah the New Republic
was never intended to be a profit-making
enterprise feel it I mean Herbert
Crowley knew the magazine was gonna lose
money and he's quoted as saying Dorothy
referring to Dorothy Payne Whitney it is
gonna get a little education for her
money but he knew she wasn't gonna
profit go back to Robert Valentine
because it was so important to your book
when you started reading in the
Massachusetts you have to go up to
Massachusetts Historical Society what a
great place to do research by the way
it's B it's a beautiful building when
did you go up there what was a year you
remember I don't know I'm guessing 1910
1911
not tonight 19 2010 2011 so did did you
have full run of the boxes I don't know
if I had full run you know but I had
enough of the correspondence that I knew
what I had I had all this correspondence
not only between Valentine and his wife
but Felix Frankfurter was writing
Valentine Valentines wife and when for
Denison is one of the original members
of the house was writing Valentine's
wife and then they were all writing each
other Dennison was writing Valentine
when he wasn't living in the house and
frankfurter was writing Valentine when
Valentine wasn't living in the house so
I had all this overlapping
correspondence which gave me as I like
to say a lot of pieces of the jigsaw
puzzle and I was able to put it together
when you're doing your research like
that what do you do with all that
information how do you catalog it well I
take digital it's a great question I
take digital photos of the documents and
then I organize the digital photos
according to box and folder numbers as
they're arranged so I can cite them and
so I can find them again and then you're
just reviewing those documents on your
computer and reading those letters and
takes time because the most of them are
written in the longhand but it's really
like reading other people's mail
or reading somebody's diary it's it's a
really
fun and and well what I really learned
from it and I think a lot of people have
missed this is that Robert Valentine was
the most important friend that Felix
Frankfurter had in the first half of
this life so I'd say before 1939 before
frankfurter got on the court there was
no more important influence on
frankfurter than Valentine he died what
year he died in 1916 quite young did I
read right that his wife died in 1953
yes what did what did she do for the
rest of her life you know she was sort
of carrying a torch for him for the rest
of her life she was kind of a sad story
she was raising her daughter but and she
was really good friends with
frankfurters wife Marion so I found some
great correspondence between her and
Mary and frankfurter who I'm described
um Sofia Valentine is kind of a shadowy
wispy figure one really poignant moment
in the book is toward the end of the
existence of the House of truth I'm
Sophia Valentine comes in stays in
Washington not far from where the house
is
and she sort of retraces the steps of
all the places where she and her late
husband had been but Marian frankfurter
stays friendly with Sophia Valentine
into the 20s and 30s and 40s let's go
back to looking physically at that house
there on 19th Street do you know who
owns it now I don't know who owns it I'm
tempted just to write a dear owner
letter do you know how many people have
owned that house since I know while I
was living in Dupont Circle that the
house was sold right and I just
remembered the sticker price I'm on the
house there it is it's that's blue trim
around the windows and on the door there
so it's sort of a white and blue house
now and it was a red brick at the time
somebody showed me a red fan shows it to
be worth a million five well I'm not I'm
not surprised I mean you know what do
you see real estate has gone I don't
think it was sold for that much money
back when it sold it sold for less money
but I I knew I didn't have that much
money let's go back to the original list
that we showed how people were back then
so that we can I want to ask you a
question of that you can see their age
ranges from 20 to up to 70 if you put
Valon
sighing homes Borglum Brandeis
frankfurter and Lippmann in that house
today
how very do you think their politics
would be and what side would they be on
in today's politics it's really hard to
do but their politics did were different
right so as I said Brandeis backed
Woodrow Wilson he was suspicious more
suspicious of a large federal government
you had Lippmann frankfurter and Borglum
who were protea Dora Roosevelt um you
had Oliver Wendell Holmes even Valentine
was extremely Pro Theodore Roosevelt and
Valentine leaves the Taft administration
as the head of the Commissioner of
Indian Affairs it's on page one of the
New York Times because he's the highest
ranking member of the Taft
administration to basically defect and
to go work for Theodore Roosevelt's
presidential campaign what would they
think though of what we just went
through and and this year and they I
mean last year in the presidential
election I think a last year's
presidential election was tame compared
to the 19 2011 12 election you had
Theodore Roosevelt challenging his
chosen successor William Howard Taft as
the Republican Party candidate when he
loses the Republican Party candidate he
runs as a third party candidate you have
a socialist part party candidate but we
haven't even talked about um Eugene Debs
who gets 900,000 votes in that election
and then you have the former President
of Princeton and Governor of New Jersey
Woodrow Wilson who as a result of all
the vote splitting among Taft and
Roosevelt and the Socialist Party
becomes the first Democrat in the White
House since girl for Cleveland and you
know that's a much more chaotic election
than the one that we just currently went
through with a lot of populism
cross-cutting
there who's responsible for naming at
the house of truths and was it a serious
that they really think they had truth no
I it was it was a completely self
mocking name for the house now the
person who's often attributed with the
name of house the truth is Holmes
because he had such a gift for language
and could really turn a phrase and but
but I don't think Holmes named the house
at truth the person who I think named
the house of truth or at least the
person who Holmes
name the house of truth was another of
its original members a guy named Winfred
Dennison who along with frankfurter and
Robert Valentine started the house how
hard was this I mean oh you got
something like 200 pages of notes how
hard it was this book to write it was it
was hard to write because I felt like I
was telling four books in one write I
was telling frankfurters story during
this period Littman's story during this
period
Borglum story during this period and
holmes the stor story during this period
and try to I don't know if I was
successful but I tried to make their
stories flow em and and not sort of
repeat myself but I still wanted
chronologically to proceed with the
story and the political and legal
developments and the way that change
over time occurred from 1912 to 1932 so
what did you want to accomplish besides
writing in this book what do you what do
you want this book to do I wanted it
show people that you know liberalism
didn't just sprout up with the election
of Franklin Roosevelt in November of
nineteen are you a liberal I mean yeah I
guess so I mean I but what I mean it's
hard to say I mean now today liberals
have rebranded themselves as
progressives I would certainly call
myself a progressive but you know I
think what happened in 1912 and at this
house of truth was liberals began to
form these networks you know networks of
politicians and lawyers and journalists
and artists and even though they weren't
in political power for much of the 1920s
and all the way up until 1932 these
networks were doing a lot of work for
them and they were really able to
undertake a lot of political change and
I think that's the major contribution in
this book to show the sort of early
developments of American liberalism a
lot of which took place at this house
any of this kind of thing going on today
where there's a house somewhere there's
salons and the tie like Washington and
oh sure I think this is a
quintessentially Washington story we're
sort of young idealistic often Ivy
League or elite college graduates coming
and live in a house together and you
know have dinner parties and and network
with various people so you know they
might be working on the hill
they might be working as counsel to a
senator so I think this is a in some
ways a quintessential Washington story
but as it in terms of forming networks
that are you know sort of changing the
world I think the Conservatives in
recent years have done a really good job
of this particularly with the federal
society you know starting in the 1980s
conservatives who have built some
incredible networks that have resulted
all the way in in the nomination and you
know of Judge Gorsuch it might be hard
to do but Oliver Wendell Holmes was on
the court for I wrote it down 10,000 and
some days he's the number 17th and
longevity what would be his biggest
legacy and we haven't got much time I
want to do that with three people but
what would be his biggest legacy Holmes
his biggest legacy are his free speech
dissents beginning with Abraham's versus
the United States that we had no free
speech jurisprudence in this country
until Holmes and then brand I started
dissenting what would have been Louis
Brandeis his biggest legacy again free
speech also um decide do you have a
constitutional right to privacy which he
had written about in Law Review articles
and also in his Olmstead to send in 1927
against wiretapping did conservatives
not believe in free speech
I think conservatives believed in free
speech but the people whose free speech
they were protecting were pretty
unpopular folks usually radical
immigrants or the people they were
standing up for people who um you know
or being prosecuted under the Espionage
Act and Felix frankfurters legacy and
you're right and now vara wary from this
book being completed light years
probably another five or six years
Felix frankfurters legacy was really a
profound belief in the federal
government and what it could accomplish
um during periods like the New Deal so
of all these people you wrote about who
do you think you would have least liked
least liked let her liked lit Lippmann
Lippmann although I admire him he's a
wonderful writer
I felt like walter Liban was out for
walter Lippmann there was really no core
there I think I would have liked him the
least and how much did you find has
already been written about him much oh
yeah
steals books fabulous there's been a lot
written about him others are still
writing about him but I think what makes
my book different than other books about
Libman about Holmes about Borglum or
about Frank Furter is these
relationships with each other and how
these are relationships with each other
impacted their lives during this period
you're gonna come to the Georgetown
University Law School you are married
and where did you meet your wife I met
my wife in Washington and DuPont circles
not far from the house of truth
how long ago she's gonna kill me for not
knowing this off the time I had about
ten years ago how many children do you
have - how old are they
four and almost six clearly they
probably haven't read your book no
they've endured the book though did they
endured the book because I said in my
acknowledgments they're my house of
truth they helped me keep it real the
house of truth is the name of the book a
Washington political salon and the
foundations of American liberalism and
our guest has been bred snider and we
thank you Brian this has been a dream
thanks
[Music]
for free transcripts or to give us your
comments about this program visit us at
Q&A org Q&A programs are also available
as c-span podcasts
[Music]